at the end of the day it's chicken
everybody needs to relax calm down it's
just chicken hey I'm Sarah Beth and I am
a former chick-fil-a employee hi my name
is Joshua I used to work at Popeyes hey
guys my name is Alisha I am a former
McDonald's employee hi I'm Victor and
I'm a former KFC employee hi my name is
Luna I used to work at Wendy's the
perfect chicken sandwich to me has to be
really well seasoned has to be crispy I
want a nice like flaky outside crunch
when you bite into it the right sauces
the right texture taste that it was like
freshly fried that's like really
important it has to just just be
something that makes you happy or also
what are the calories for
my pleasure mmm mmm so good
chick-fil-a is the king of kings when it
comes to chicken sandwiches oh I know
what this is
yes a smells really good I like the way
the bread looks definitely a hefty piece
of chicken not a super big fan of
pickles but when they complement and
they work together in a sandwich I'm all
for it and you could tell by the actual
fibers in the meat that it's a real
chicken breast which is definitely what
I'm looking for in a chicken sandwich
[Music]
amazing I do have one critique though
and that is I don't like the bun it's
really buttery but otherwise just
high-quality chicken so good oh my gosh
this reminds me of high school Peron I
can taste the controversy like I mean
other than the fact that the LGBTQ I
mean there's nothing else about it I
mean I would eat it every day
this one looks wack okay there's one
single pickle on the bottom but okay
there's two pickles right on top of each
other right in the center of the bun so
I'm not sure like what good that's doing
anyone if you're like going from the
side the bread is kind of just like limp
and soggy you know it feels like it's
been floating in like the wave pool at
like an amusement park for like the past
like hour to like honestly um I don't
like this very much as this chick-fil-a
yeah I don't I don't really care for
this very much I feel like I've had
better chick-fil-a sandwiches though
honestly so I don't know maybe this this
particular one is just like cursed you
know out of ten I'll give this one solid
9 we give it an 8 gotta give it an 8
because you know what there's always
room to improve the chicken and the
bread are both delicious by themselves
so putting them both together definitely
puts them out of strong eight for me if
I was just over the bread it'd be like a
five this is like a 1 out of 10 I don't
want to continue eating it
[Laughter]
I love the KMC Jenga sandwich it's an
awesome piece of chicken breast the
bread is bangin it's got like a nice
shininess to it you know like typical
brioche bun they use an awesome mayo on
it put a pickle all together everything
combines awesome awesome chicken
sandwich real good bun not soggy not
hard not flaky it's nice and shiny we
got a good bun
we got good seasons on the chicken we
got a nice sauce - chicken ratio my one
criticism is they're hella pickles on
here that's good has good seasoning I
really like the crisp of the chicken
it's a it's a big old piece of chicken
it's like a giant chicken tender I
really like the bread I like the sauce
everything about it's pretty good so
bomb Wow at all of them I think this one
has the most flavoring for sure the
chicken the bread is really really good
- like I love bread and this bread is
amazing you can just tell it it's like
butter because the top of it is shiny I
would definitely eat this like that
least twice a week
[Music]
I don't know it's kind of thin like I
feel like it's kind of a thin piece of
chicken which is I'm not a big fan of
that the breading is kind of like soggy
which is like I'm also not a fan of yeah
I'm not impressed with this it's kind of
like it feels like it's been like eaten
out like it looks kind of like sad like
it looks like the kid in like middle
school who just found out his parents
got divorced and like love isn't real
like but a sandwich you know what I mean
it's a date it's a solid eight seven I'd
give this someone like a solid eight I
would give it like a three out of ten
because the lack of condiments that the
lack of effort like also I feel like on
behalf of it and like half of like the
chicken is just like this like thin like
breading I don't know not bad I really
like the McDonald's chicken sandwich
because it's aesthetically pleasing you
have that big beautiful bun the crispy
lettuce tomato and so good
shiny fast food fun delightful little
baby tomatoes they'll take a nice flaky
crust let's see I'm actually really not
sure what this is from but the piece of
chicken is ginormous so I love that
already the breading is actually pretty
decent it actually has a crunch to it
I guess I'd never really McDonald so I
didn't know that they actually could
actually have a good chicken sandwich
dry I love McDonald's I purposely go to
McDonald's at 3 in the morning to not
feel hungry I will eat this any day for
the fact that it is McDonald's but not
necessarily because it's the best
chicken sandwich I've ever had I'm not a
big fan of the seasoning on this one the
bread was a little bit just not it's
like springy and soft as other
sandwiches might be it really didn't
I mean it tastes like McDonald's you
know like you can count on it to be
mediocre you know what I mean like it's
not gonna be bad it's not gonna be good
like it's just you can count on it to be
just kind of okay
I feel like McDonald's is perfect like
like I just had like a bad day and like
I want food that like is my bad day in
food form you know what I mean like I
had like like I feel mediocre so I'm
gonna eat some mediocre food and like
hopefully that'll make me feel better I
don't know I think it's better than the
KFC one but I'm also not impressed I
gotta say six out of ten I would say
it's like a strong six I would give it
if I had to rank it I would give it like
a five out of ten um ranking is like a
six and I'm not mad at you know what
news has got it right with her classic
chicken sandwich she's got the lettuce
the tomato the Mayo but we'll see if I
guess you could tell by the little
pepper bits this is most certainly a
McDonald's McChicken sandwich I think
let me see I'm gonna try it on that
[Music]
classroom
hmm that's cute not too much playback
it's not the best thing I've ever eaten
but I would eat it
could be a little crispy err but it's
good I would say my main critique is
where's the spice at you know I need a
little I need a little bit of that that
boom it is a little me foamy inside but
very good taste classic chicken sandwich
defi among my favourite ones in the
whole lineup of fast food chicken
sandwiches I would not feed this to my
grandma I love you grandma
if I had to rank this sandwich from 1 to
10 I would give it like a 3 I'd give it
like a 4 and I would give this in which
is 6 I want to give this one a solid 7
just not my chicken you're lying
no it's not one dude
pretty bangin though I guess nonetheless
[Music]
the Popeye chicken sandwich laughs
everybody knows that it's last and if
you haven't tried it you're missing out
I mean I've seen a lot of crazy stuff
like on Twitter and just on social media
people by getting into fights and doing
some really extra stuff that I probably
wouldn't do for a chicken sandwich but
if it was like the last chicken sandwich
I pop I've you know I probably would I
probably those enhancer I check us out
I'm not gonna okay this is a big piece
of chicken that's a big boy this one
probably weighs about a pound by itself
that's exciting
I'm gonna taste okay that one's really
good Wow the star of this sandwich is
the flakiness on the outside this is so
good it's a nice dollop of mayo the
pickles complements really nicely I
gotta say yeah this looks like it would
be pretty expensive no I know when
people are getting beat up over this
this is good
[Music]
yeah good I have stopped eating this I
would finish that host name yourself
[Music]
yeah not the best so far
this baby is a ten nine and a half just
because I don't think ten exists this is
this is pretty close if I had to give
this a rating I'd give it an 8 out of 10
because it's a great sandwich it's got
great chicken great condiments but the
bread is where it's really lacking it's
real just like smoosh down I feel like
you know the chicken deserve butter
frankly in terms of the bread so I'm
gonna give it a 5 so Popeyes won
I knew it I set up in the jump Popeyes
is the best people don't stand in those
lines and have those fights for nothing
I mean there's a reason that all that
stuff is all over social media Twitter
and Facebook and whatnot I knew they
were gonna win I hide it
[Music]
[Music]